writer David Gator is leaving Bioware  Gator announced his departure on his  Twitter saying I must sadly announced  that after 17 years today is my last day  at Bioware Gator started working at  Bioware in 1999 as a writer and designer  on such games as Baldur's Gate two  knights of the old republic and number  winter nights he would later work on the  Dragon Age franchise including dragon  age origins dragon age 2 and Inquisition  Gator mentioned to polygon that his  decision to leave bioware was amicable  for his next move Gator said he'll make  an announcement in due time we here at  gamespot wish Gator the very best on his  next move for more gaming news keep it  at gamespot